los expertos de la organización mundial
de la salud están finalmente en la cuna
de la epidemia mujer ha pasado un poco
más de un año desde que china anunció la
primera muerte porque si nueve en esa
ciudad
el grupo internacional de expertos tiene
que hacer primero una cuarentena durante
este periodo los científicos chinos y
expertos médicos estarán en una extensa
comunicación con los expertos
internacionales a través de
videoconferencia
sobre si visitaran otras partes de china
creo que tendrán que antes completar su
primera parada su investigación en wuhan
antes de poder considerar su pregunta
sin embargo las autoridades chinas
impidieron la entrada de dos miembros
del equipo después de que dieron
positivo en las pruebas de anticuerpos
en singapur china asegura estar
aplicando las medidas preventivas de
manera estricta inicialmente prevista la
semana pasada la llegada de los expertos
fue cancelada en el último minuto debido
a que beijing no había transmitido todas
las autorizaciones necesarias pero los
residentes de wuhan acogieron con
satisfacción la visita es un poco tarde
para que vengan pero más vale tarde que
nunca será útil para ellos encontrar los
orígenes de la enfermedad en el lugar en
donde surgió por primera vez la llegada
de la misión de la oea se coincide con
la noticia sobre un nuevo fallecimiento
por el coronavirus en china primera
muerte que se produce en ocho meses en
el país los expertos dudan que esta
primera misión arroje resultados
concluyentes sobre los orígenes del
virus